Joker is officially the highest-grossing
r-rated film of all time and the star of
the previous champ Deadpool had a couple
of choice words about the development
the reliably hilarious Ryan Reynolds
took to Instagram to post a mock poster
for Joker offering congrats on behalf of
himself and well the subjects have past
r-rated box-office smashes if you are at
all familiar with Reynolds you already
have a pretty solid idea of what to
expect and we can say with certainty
that you won't be disappointed
Reynolds tagged Joker director Todd
Phillips in the image and captioned it
our rated box office congratulatory
posts aren't like the ones you're used
to no we should say not and neither are
congratulatory posts from Deadpool whom
we all know is a kind of insane and be
in no way a fictional character as long
as Reynolds is breathing there our
superhero actors who embody their roles
and then there is Reynolds who probably
sleeps in his costume and has an
unhealthy relationship with his katanas
dear old fake laugh hiding real pain go
get silver balls for those keeping score
at home the movies Reynolds refers to at
the bottom of the poster are in order
Deadpool The Matrix it's chapter 1 The
Passion of the Christ
Logan The Hangover 50 shades of grey and
Ted highest-grossing r-rated movie ever
becomes the latest in a long line of
superlatives bestowed upon the joaquin
phoenix starring joker since its release
which already include biggest october
opener of all time Golden Lion award
winner and odds on oscar favorite of
course since they have a slightly
narrower audience it's a little tougher
for r-rated films to do the kind of
bonkers box office that say Marvel
Studios pg-13 offerings often do no
r-rated flick has ever broken the
billion-dollar mark at the worldwide box
office but Joker might very well be the
first in order to get even close it's
done away with some pretty formidable
competition as Reynolds pointed out in
his uniquely smartass fashion that's one
heck of a slate of films that Deadpool
there herb Reynolds rather made
reference to on that poster being huge
geeks we decided to do a little digging
to see just how much
box office gold they represent let's
take them in chronological order
starting with the oldest flick on the
list the matrix it's interesting to note
that the film came out twenty years ago
and its total of just over four hundred
sixty three million dollars was enough
to hand at the r-rated crown it was also
a bonafide pop culture phenomenon
spawning two sequels and a multimedia
franchise that includes comic books
video games and animated shorts yet it
still couldn't crack the half billion
dollar barrier adjusted for inflation
though the total is closer to seven
hundred million dollars next on the list
2004 is the passion of the christ' which
benefited from having a pretty sizable
built-in audience and which also
dominated the pop culture conversation
in the year of its release the flick
cleaned up worldwide to the tune of six
hundred and ten million dollars eight
hundred and twenty nine million dollars
adjusted for inflation and it stayed on
top for a surprisingly long time this is
because the next two on the list only
earned the title of highest-grossing
r-rated comedy The Hangover released in
2009 scored a four hundred sixty eight
million dollar worldwide gross and it
held the raunchy comedy crown until it
was bested in 2012 by Seth MacFarlane's
Ted which notched a five hundred forty
nine million dollar global take 2015's
Fifty Shades of Grey while a huge hit
fell short of passions total by about
forty million dollars making it an
outlier on Reynolds list we're inclined
to believe that he's well aware of this
and threw it in because he wanted to
include a really popular movie with lots
of steamy scenes for a laugh if you're
unconvinced we refer you to pretty much
everything the guy has ever posted on
Twitter it took 12 years and the first
long-awaited solo vehicle for the Merc
with a mouth to formerly dethrone Jesus
as 2016 s Deadpool smashed all kinds of
records enroute to a whopping 782
million dollars for eight hundred thirty
six million dollars adjusted box office
total that film has technically worn the
crown ever since as the remaining two
movies on Reynolds lists actually failed
to knock it from its perch 2017 in
Chapter one became the highest grossing
horror movie of all time with a 700
million dollar take while Logan super
violent swan song
for Reynolds buddy Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine only managed 619 million
dollars
Logan's inclusion on Reynolds lists was
probably simply a shout-out to his
friend or given how much the pair enjoy
antagonizing each other perhaps it was a
mention of a more passive-aggressive
variety Logan didn't come close to
matching the total of either Deadpool
movie whoo okay back to joker here all
caught on joker has raked in an
eye-watering eight hundred fifty two
million dollars globally and the flick
has some extremely long legs it handily
won its first two weekends came very
close to winning its next two and it's
per weekend drop-off has been
significantly less pronounced than most
tentpole pictures including fellow
worlds of DC titles like Aquaman
the only billion-dollar success for the
franchise so far it seems only a matter
of time before Joker goes barreling past
the billion dollar mark and it's tough
to imagine that any movie will challenge
it for the r-rated crown anytime soon
even Deadpool 3 which is almost
certainly in the works and matrix for
which is definitely in the works seem
unlikely to score that big at the box
office but if the franchisees were to
team up they just might pull it off
don't try to tell us you know even a
single person who wouldn't pay good
money to see Deadpool breaks the matrix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]